immer eine grüne ampel 17 jahre länger
leben und wie bakterien krebs heilen
können das sind 3 wird eben jetzt in den
top-5 news vom krieg zum science fiction
wie bei hot stocks ampeln gehackt jede
ampel auf grün stellen können das ist
der wunsch jedes autofahrers genau das
haben forscher aus den usa im
bundesstaat michigan ausprobiert und
auch geschafft dabei entdeckten sie
massive sicherheitslücken im verkehrs
regelungssystem die ampeln seien über
einfache wlan schnittstellen anwählbar
das umschalten fällt dank vorgegebener
benutzernamen und passwörtern die
öffentlich einsehbar sind sehr leicht
wie auch im videospiel hot stocks in dem
ein hacker ähnliche möglichkeiten hat
ampeln zu hacken konnten die forscher um
james holden von der university in
michigan am ende über 100 ampeln im
bundesstaat kontrollieren den test
werden die wissenschaftler nun an die
betreffenden behörden weiterreichen
der sicherheitsexperte sie saß herr udo
der firma activ labs ist nicht
überrascht von den ergebnissen der
forschergruppe er kritisiert dass die
entwickler der software fehler machen
die bereits vor zehn jahren schon
passiert sind mehr als 40 staaten in der
usa benutzen derzeit übrigens dieses
ampelsystem besonders bemängeln die
wissenschaftler dass die lücken in der
software auf mangelndes
sicherheitsbewusstsein zurückgehen und
nicht auf fehler in der bauweise der
geräte wo genau sie ihre test allerdings
durchgeführt haben können sie aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht veröffentlichen
der versuche zeigen jedoch dass mit den
einfachsten mitteln jede ampel beliebig
angesteuert werden kann
17 jahre länger leben
übermäßiger tabak und alkoholkonsum
sowie langfristiges übergewicht rauben
den menschen etwa 17 jahre an lebenszeit
das haben forscher im deutschen
krebsforschungszentrum herausgefunden
in einer studie mit über 25.000
teilnehmern untersuchten sie die genauen
einflüsse von fettleibigkeit
nikotinsucht und alkoholismus
dabei legten sie auch wert auf das
risiko durch die kombination der
genannten faktoren das übergewicht
rauchen und der regelmäßige verzehr von
alkohol nicht gesund sind ist allgemein
bekannt
die wissenschaftler um rudolf kaaks vom
deutschen krebsforschungszentrum den
ging es in ihrer kürzlich
veröffentlichten studie allerdings darum
zu errechnen wie viel lebenszeit durch
die 1
den risiken verloren gehen denn alle
drei faktoren fügen unserem körper
schäden zu die ihn zunehmend altern
lassen
vor allem das rauchen kostet laut der
studie die meiste lebenszeit bis zehn
zigaretten am tag da verliert ein mann
bis zu 94 jahre und bei frauen sind es
73 jahre am gesündesten lebt nach den
berechnungen der wissenschaftler ein
nichtraucher mit einem body mass index
zwischen 22 45 9 das verhältnis von
größe und gewicht der wenig alkohol
konsumiert und vor allem obst und gemüse
ist jedoch treten bei den meisten
menschen mehrere der ungesunden
angewohnheiten zusammen auf was auch der
grund für diese studie war in ihrer
arbeit untersuchten die forscher die
zusammenhänge und
kombinationsmöglichkeiten der einzelnen
faktoren und errechneten die verlorene
lebenserwartung das ergebnis ist
erwartungsgemäß wer viel trinkt also zu
viel trinkt raucht und übergewichtig ist
kann bis zu 17 jahre seines lebens
verlieren wir haben keine rohstoffe mehr
der wwf der world wide found hat den
neunzehnter august 2014 zum diesjährigen
welt schöpfungstag ausgerufen
grund ist die ausbeutung der rohstoffe
auf unserem planeten
für das aktuelle jahr haben wir bereits
jetzt die rohstoff menge gefördert die
für 2014 zur verfügung stand die
verbleibenden viereinhalb monate
entziehen wie der erde also mehr als die
menschheit in diesem jahr eigentlich
bekommen dürfte einen tag früher als
2013 drei tage früher als 2012 das ist
die bilanz des welttags das problem ist
dass die menschheit viel mehr rohstoffe
verbraucht als der erde eigentlich zur
verfügung stehen
wir verwandeln ressourcen schneller in
abfälle als dass abfälle in ressourcen
umgewandelt werden können schreibt die
organisation global footprint networks
auf ihrer homepage sie verfolgen den
verbrauch an natürlichen rohstoffen und
die ressourcen kapazität der welt über
jahre hinweg das schlimme ist dass wir
schon seit 30 jahren zu viel verbrauchen
in island ein vulkan auszubrechen
zurzeit besteht alarmstufe orange ein
ausbruch des isländischen vulkans
eyjafjallajokull hoffe das habe ich
richtig ausgesprochen im ganzen land und
auch in europa sind meteorologen in
alarmbereitschaft
im direkten umkreis des vulkans wurden
jetzt auch menschen evakuiert da
anzeichen von magma bewegungen einen
ausbruch vermuten lassen
bislang mussten etwa 70 touristen ihre
unterkünfte nahe dem vatnajökull
gletscher räumen
seit samstag waren dort tausende
erdbeben gemessen worden und deshalb
wurden jetzt die evakuierung von den
isländischen behörden angeordnet ja etwa
70 waren direkt in der nähe mussten also
evakuiert werden
aber ansonsten leben dort keine menschen
denn der vulkan ist regelmäßig aktiv und
bricht regelmäßig aus allein in der
zeitspanne vom letzten samstag bis
montag abend wurden laut des
meteorologischen instituts in island
2600 erdbeben registriert und das
stärkste von ihnen erreichte einen wert
von 4,5 auf der richterskala
obwohl keine 100 prozentige sicherheit
besteht dass der vulkan ausbricht wurde
die zweithöchste alarmstufe orange
ausgerufen
da es anzeichen von magma bewegungen
gibt sind eine oder sogar mehrere
eruptionen möglich und die auswirkung
eines solchen ausbruchs wären dramatisch
und zwar für ganz europa denn zum einen
durch die entweichende hitze würde ein
großteil des gletscher schmelzen der
sich in der nähe des vulkans befindet
das hätte lokale überschwemmungen zur
folge und die freigesetzte asche das e
mails bei europa die in die luft
geschleudert wird würde den flugverkehr
eben europaweit mehrere tage behindert
ähnlich war es im jahr 2010
damals hat der vulkan sogar den
flugverkehr in europa vollends
lahmgelegt ja und aktuell sind übrigens
30 vulkane auf island aktiv und im
durchschnitt bricht alle fünf jahre
einer von ihnen aus
bakterien highland krebs bestimmte
veränderte bakterien können krebs
gezielt von innen heraus zerstören die
umliegenden zellen werden dabei kaum
angegriffen
bei der behandlung kommen spezielle
bakterien zum einsatz die vor allem
unter ausschluss von sauerstoff arbeiten
also optimal für das innere eines tumors
die methode wurde bisher vor allem an
hunden getestet aber auch die behandlung
einer krebspatientin zeigte positive
ergebnisse die verantwortlichen
wissenschaftler hoffen durch die weitere
verbesserung der behandlung auf eine
effektive methode zur bekämpfung von
krebs die idee krebszellen mit bakterien
zu bekämpfen ist allerdings nicht ganz
neu schon in den 1800 neunziger jahren
beobachtete ein arzt dass einige seiner
patienten die nach einer krebsoperation
eine bakterieninfektion bekam einen
heilungs fortschritt machten
da der versuch eine funktionierende
behandlung zu entwickeln scheiterte gab
es vorerst keine neuen studien dazu
diese idee wurde jetzt allerdings neu
aufgegriffen in dem verfahren werden die
bakterien zunächst manipuliert das
bedeutet die bakterien sind nicht mehr
in der lage einen bestimmten giftstoff
zu bilden danach werden die sporen ein
entwicklungsstadium der bakterien in die
sie sich nicht teilen direkt in einem
tumor injiziert
dort entwickeln sich die sporen wieder
die bakterien und beginnen den tumor
innerlich zu zerstören
durch die therapie werden infektions
entscheidungen wie fieber und
entzündungsreaktionen hervorrufen
in versuchen an krebskranken wunden
zeigte die therapie allerdings in sechs
von 16 fällen einen sensationellen
erfolg
mehr über einen sensationellen fall bei
dem eine patientin innerhalb von
kürzester zeit mit masernviren geheilt
wurde gibt es in diesem video hier krebs
spontan geheilt hat dafür im hier
klicken und täglich news über science
und fiction findet ihr im klicks und
blog ein klick hier und ihr seid da
allerdings wie immer auch in dem video
beschreibung bis dann bleibt dran